joining me now to discuss this and more
is the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis mr lewis thank you so much
for joining us woefully inadequate what
do you think
well i think we've got to remember with
we've just seen coming through from the
chancellor a packager that's worth about
22 billion pounds of support for people
that doesn't of course change the fact
that this is a difficult period we're
seeing that with the pressure on energy
prices globally we're seeing that in the
pressure
we're seeing across the economy as we're
coming out of covid and we recognize
that that's why the chancellor took the
actions he did in the statement just as
the week before last and it's something
that was a government we always keep
under view and we did through kovid we
put the support in that the country and
the people and businesses needed
and we will continue to keep these
things under review to do everything we
can within the context of what is
achievable in terms of what the
government can do
you mentioned covid and an argument
being made is that you did so much
during covid and yet for this
choices were made and you're not doing
as much as you could
well one of the things the chancellor
and the prime minister and all of us in
government have to continually look at
is the whole the picture right across
the board so yes as we came through
covet i think we have shown as a
government we will do everything we can
to stand by people to support people and
businesses across the united kingdom and
we will continue to do that we've got to
also as i say in that whole picture get
look at the balance of things because
obviously we're at a position at the
moment where with what we've done the
unprecedented support through covid uh
we've now got a position where the
government's got very very high uh
borrowing rates that does have an impact
for people in the medium and long term
as well because obviously that buying at
some so you have to pay interest on that
that has to gradually be repaid
we've got to get the balance right
without at the same time doing what we
can to give people support where there
is a global pressure and we know there
was a global pressure on energy prices
even before putin's invasion of ukraine
that has obviously had a further impact
on costs of living across the globe
energy not least of all so that's why we
put this package in as i say it's worth
about 22 billion pounds we've seen just
this week and i think it was just
yesterday actually the increase in the
national living wage has a beneficial
impact for people the change in the
threshold has a beneficial impact for
people both worth about a thousand
pounds so we've now seen actually the
biggest reduction in taxes a package
that we've seen for about a quarter of a
century and we're putting support into
local authorities reducing fuel duty all
of these things
to try and give people the support we
can up against that pressure that we're
seeing globally and across markets
um it is support that you've given and
you're throwing these big numbers around
and yes they are very big but at the end
of the day this is about people and
people's lives will be put at risk
well that's why we're putting the
support in i absolutely
appreciate we all do the challenge on
this uh all of us are affected by energy
prices i know even this week
where i live where we're on oil fire
heating we i've seen that change
directly in in the price of oil and
actually the ability to get it my home
my family went a few days where we had
no oil just waiting for the for the
suppliers and seen the the the very big
increase in price on that but as i say
it goes we will do everything we can to
give people support with the balance of
what is going on in the wider economy
and making sure we're continuing to
invest and spend in the public sector in
the areas that people want to see it
that's why we've put that big package of
support in chancellor and the prime
minister have both been very clear we'll
continue to look at this
as we go through the year we can't
completely nullify the impacts of the
global markets and global pressure for
example on energy which is obviously the
main focus at the moment
for most people
but we will put in the support that we
can as and when we can as i say looking
at across the board at what we're doing
with the public's money
if if if you're saying that you can
you're doing everything that you can
why don't you tax
the oil and gas companies who are making
so much money
people have to decide between eating and
heating i know we use that phrase so
much but if you say that you are doing
everything you can
why don't you tax them
well i do understand why people look to
that i mean the only thing i would say
labor have been making this point for a
while what they're not able to answer
and
i i think is a is an odd situation is
the reality of what is happening in the
energy market this is first of all this
is a global pressure we're seeing this
around the world so what we do with
companies here in the uk won't have the
impact of changing the whole global
energy market prices but we should also
remember that those energy companies
here in the uk are already paying about
40 percent
tax that's roughly double what most
sectors in the uk economy are paying
they employ hundreds of thousands of
people in the uk we're looking at them
and they are investing hugely um in more
work to develop more energy and produce
more energy they need the income that
they have to make those investments and
the part they play in the economy paying
salaries so a windfall tax on those
companies won't necessarily have the
impact on global prices that people
think it will it can have an impact on
some domestic prices by taxing higher a
sector that is already very very highly
taxed so although that is a very it
sounds an attractive option in the wider
economic context it doesn't really work
and that's why we've looked at what can
we do that will have a beneficial impact
directly for people in their pockets and
that's why this money both the rebates
on council tax the increase in the
national living wage and its threshold
are things that will mean that people
have more money in their pockets to be
able to manage the pressures that
they're finding well if we're talking
about people having more money in their
pockets why don't you restore the 20
pound a week uplift and universal credit
that would give people more money in
their pockets and 20 pounds a week is a
lot of money
yes it is but as i say what we are
looking at is the decisions we have to
make around where we put that support so
we've put that support in by reducing
fuel duty which is a benefit for
everybody at 5p reduction something that
everybody who's using fuel to get around
get to work and back everybody will
benefit from that over the next year
we're putting hundreds of millions of
pounds into local authorities to help
the most vulnerable people with the
support that they need
local authorities know best what they
need in their area in terms of how to
support people we've put that increase
in in the national living wage we put
the increasing in the national insurance
threshold
so everybody who is earning and people
on the national living wage will have an
increase in their pocket
effectively partly through those tax
reductions but also through the increase
in the national living wage so very
targeted at the people who are most in
need
targeted the people who are most in need
but tsukiosama has called it a pathetic
response
well look t kiyosama is is going to play
politics for this he's already as i say
come up with something he thinks sounds
catchy with a windfall tax but in
reality as i've explained doesn't
necessarily and doesn't really work
doesn't answer the problems uh that's
the benefit of being in opposition i
would say in government we've got to
look at that wider picture to make sure
we are building an economy and the
decisions the prime minister has made i
mean we've now got one of if not
arguably the fastest growing economy in
the g7 that's creating jobs we've got
people backing work to the levels they
were if not higher than they were
pre-covered that in the long term is
good for our economy it's good for
people's uh income and
home personal security of finance and
we're putting these financial measures
in place to support people and we will
keep that under view as we did all the
way through kobe so we're focused on
doing the things that practically work
and make a positive difference for
people every day and looking at making
the right medium and long-term
investments for our wider economy and
the jobs opportunity in the future
okay let's talk about ukraine now you
did mention ukraine um
in the uh in the papers this morning
claims that ukrainian forces have had
success with what is britain's most
advanced portable missile system do you
think that our help although we haven't
actually gone in there is helping the
ukrainians
oh look
absolutely and we've seen that the
ukrainians themselves both the president
and the wider community have been clear
uh about their their the support that
the uk as part of that global
partnership have given and i do think
the prime minister the team have led the
way i'm as northern ireland section i'm
fortunate to see some of this uh work
directly literally just yesterday i was
uh in the factory in belfast that's
producing some of those weapons that are
being sent out to ukraine uh
i think probably the ones you're you're
just talking about and the pride of
people in northern ireland as i know
across the uk the support we're able to
give his palpable i think it's the right
thing to do uh in the long term it's the
right thing for the west to support a
free democracy of sovereign democracy
like ukraine and do everything we can
it's it's it's such a barbaric situation
what we're seeing with what putin has
done this it's absolutely important
so how what do you think we're going to
do keep on doing what we're doing more
sanctions more military aid
is that what we're going to do
yes look we've i think we're leading the
world at the moment in terms of
sanctions and putting that pressure on
the uh the russian economy
one of the shames of this is this you
know the russian this is not about the
russian people it's about putin's regime
and what he is doing and we've got to
put the pressure on them
and show that their invasion will not
work will have
negative impacts on
on their regime those sanctions that
we've put in over a thousand people and
and businesses across evolved with
russia
has that effect the support we have
given and again we led the way the
defense sector and the prime minister
very much leading the way at the very
early stages of that uh lethal defense
support that we have put into
um ukraine which they have been very
grateful and put into very good use to
defend themselves and as i say i'm very
proud that a big a big part of that has
been something that's come from uh the
people and businesses in northern
ireland that are producing uh that
weaponry to give ukraine the support
that it needs
let's talk about partygate and um scan
news understands those first finds have
been sent out by email we still don't
know to who do you think we will ever
know who has been fined who will be
fined and do you think we should we have
a right to know
well i i i don't know what um
individuals they they will do will do
the prime minister's been very clear
actually and uh that if the prime
minister were to be fined he would be
he would go public with that he'd be
open about that uh when fires were
issued across a range of things that the
the police work on uh that they don't
put that in the public domain it's a
matter for individuals that's just a i
know the individuals involved in this
are able to benefit from the same uh
rule of law that anybody else would if
they were fine that's a matter for them
i don't know before you ask
who hasn't has me fine but i can confirm
that if the prime minister fined that he
would make that public and just the
prime minister
well so it's a matter for individuals
what we don't know as well when we talk
about these fines is whether it's a
number of people or a number of fines
i've seen
because obviously
people could have more than one finance
we don't know the details of that the
obviously the met police themselves are
still continuing their investigation
when that completes we'll then have a
final concluding report from sue gray to
complete the work that she did obviously
she published that first stage report
before the metropolitan police
investigation really got underway and
that's the point of which we'll have the
full facts to be able to have a wider
conversation about what happened but as
i say the prime minister as i said
before has already previously outlined
his apology to people for what happened
how things were handled uh but we've got
to let the met police and the sue grey
complete their work to get that that
full
picture okay mr lewis thank you so much
for talking to us my pleasure